well if you've ever been given a family
piece of jewelry passed down to you but
want to turn it into something you
really love Michael E Minden Diamond
Jewelers the sponsors of the segment can
help you do just that take a look well
we're here at Fashion Show to talk all
things diamonds my favorite things and
we found the perfect person to help us
Michael evening great to see you Jillian
come on in thanks for having us let's go
inside so Michael we are comfortable now
and I am so excited to talk to you I've
been wanting to talk to you because I am
very fortunate that I've been passed
down some very special pieces of jewelry
from my family but I don't know exactly
what to do with them so I brought them
with me today can we take a look at them
what's really wonderful Jillian is that
we can use little parts of all of the
gold pieces so that you have some of
everybody and I can put that into the
new ring that's going to be white gold
even though it's yellow gold will you
see any hints of the yellow and the
white we we now have a special
technology where the recipe of what we
use overtakes the yellow so it'll be
white all the time you just don't use a
lot lot of the yellow but you're going
to use some of it and that way everybody
can be with you with what you're going
to get I love that and I did not even
know that was possible and as we're
laying all these pieces out here there's
something else I want to talk about as
we're getting organized my ring over
here my engagement ring my grandma left
me her diamond and it's always been so
special to me she passed away about six
years ago and I've only been married for
about a year and a half but let's say
I'm officially ready for a new setting
and maybe I want to learn a little bit
more about the diamond that she gave me
can you help with all of that absolutely
from size to shape to age to Clarity
Michael E Minden can teach you
everything you need to know about your
estate pieces this is what they call a
round brilliant
from the way that it's cut it looks like
it's maybe about 70 80 years old I don't
see hardly any inclusions in it just
some very small ones it's the size of a
two and a half carat
because of how it's cut it's very deep
underneath it's kind of how they did it
back in the day and so this could be
very close to three carats total yeah
and for anyone if they come in and they
want to know about a piece of jewelry a
diamond this is something you can do
right here on the spot yes and all
evaluations are absolutely free but if
you want to start from scratch the
sparkly pieces are endless we are
blessed we're the wedding ring store of
the city and we try to have the
selection of 50 times what anybody has
we have something for everybody and
everything that you see we make so we
have a factory right above us on the
second floor and like a genie you can
point to anything and if you want it in
rose gold white gold yellow gold and
it's in white we can change anything and
make it in your size and make it perfect
for whatever Center Stone you want we
sell natural diamonds we sell lab grown
diamonds very popular we also do very
new Progressive things where we put
sapphires or emeralds or or rubies as
the Center Stone into a client's ring
for their Center Stone in an engagement
ring and there's always the option to
turn in your estate jewelry to put
towards future jewelry Jillian if you
have anything else at home anything
that's unwanted broken diamonds gold
colored stones even watches sometimes
even costume jewelry you can bring it
all in for a free evaluation and we'll
buy it all from you and cash you out or
put it towards something brand new
whatever you'd like thank you so much
I'm coming back to see you okay I'm here
thank you to Michael Eamonn and Diamond
Jewelers for sponsoring this segment
they are located on the top floor of
fashion show mall you can visit
lovemyjeweler.com or call
702-253-5588 for more information